Speaker 1: So earlier in the show, we talked about
the hearings that took place yesterday, primarily
about the January 6th Trump riots, and we spoke
about Merrick Garland and other Biden officials
explaining in very clear terms white supremacists
are the top domestic terror threat. That wasn't
really the main focus of these hearings. The
main focus of these hearings was actually
what on earth happened on January 6th. And one
of the big questions about January 6th has been,
did Trump get asked to deploy the National
Guard early and refused? Did Donald Trump not
think about it? What exactly explained the delay
where we were still watching in the 4:00 p.m.
Eastern hour and there were no National Guard and
the riots had been going on for hours. Protesters
and rioters and insurrectionists had breached
the Capitol building. People had already died,
et cetera, et cetera. Well, yesterday, during
testimony and this is just unbelievable, Trump's
former acting secretary of defense confirmed that
Donald Trump did not approve the plan to deploy
the National Guard until Mike Pence called him
more than three hours after the capital riot began
yesterday. This was the testimony from Chris
Miller. Chris Miller was Trump's acting defense
secretary for that last period of the Trump
administration. And he said that it was a more
than three hour delay from when the capital riot
started, to when Donald Trump actually authorized
the National Guard to go in. And of course, we
know that it took a while for the National Guard
to actually get on site. It was already starting
to really become evening when that really took
place. And it took a phone call from Mike Pence
convincing him to do it before he was actually
willing to sign off on that. At first, former
acting defense secretary Chris Miller testified
that he gave full authorization to deploy members
of the National Guard at 3:00 p.m., which was
about two hours, remember, right around 1:00 p.m.
Eastern. We were all watching it live. We were
streaming live about 1:00 p.m. is when the breach
started. Three p.m. is initially what Chris Miller
said was the timing. Miller was then questioned by
New York Congresswoman Alexandria Cassio Cortez,
and she started going more specifically
into the timeline of January 6th. And
then we eventually learned that actually
the National Guard was not authorized
to go to the Capitol until four thirty
two p.m. Eastern Time. And the delay,
it's a little nebulous what the delay even was
part of it was coming up with a plan for exactly
how it would be done and so on and so
forth. But what's really interesting is that
the the testimony revealed a conversation between
Miller and Mike Pence at 4:00 eight p.m. and AOC
asked, did Pence direct you to clear the building?
And Miller said, Well, I had a very brief
conversation with Mike Pence where we we agreed
that the building would be cleared, but the order
to actually do it was not issued until later after
a conversation with the mayor of Washington, D.C.,
after a conversation with Speaker Nancy Pelosi,
after a conversation with Senate. At the time,
it was Senate Minority Leader Chuck Schumer.
And it was three hours after the mayor of D.C.
actually asked for that deployment. So there
are really a couple of possibilities here.
Neither of them is particularly good. And I would
kind of summarize them as either incompetence or
what some some might call treason, others might
call indifference. I don't know. One possibility
is Trump and his executive branch realize
the danger of what was going on right away.
They understood the urgency of getting the
National Guard in quickly, but it took them three
and a half hours to do it because they were either
inept or they couldn't figure out how to do it
or they were slow or whatever. So that makes them
weak. That makes them incompetent. That makes them
everything that they showed us they are during
the Trump administration. That's one possibility.
The second possibility is, in a sense, maybe even
worse, which is that Trump knew exactly what was
going on on January 6th, starting at 1:00 p.m. and
we believe that he did because we are aware of the
fact that he was everybody at the White House was
watching what was going on up and that he chose to
delay or not to send National Guard to the Capitol
because of the political orientation of the people
who were writing, which were Trump's. Supporters
and of course, that unfortunately seems to me the
more likely explanation and the reason I say that
is we know that Donald Trump and everybody at the
White House were watching what was going on. We
have reports that Trump was increasingly getting
agitated and annoyed that the rioters looked low
class. And as Trump supporters made Donald Trump
look bad, which is absolutely something you only
say if you have an understanding of what it is
that is going on. And so if you ask me, was this
incompetence or was this a malicious attitude, I
probably lean towards the malicious attitude based
on everything I know. If you are coming away with
this, from this with a different perspective, let
me know. But every time we learn something new,
every time there's a new revelation, it points not
only to incompetence by the Trump administration.
Yes, there was plenty of incompetence, but
it points to an uncaring, malicious and in
some cases borderline treasonous perspective
to what was going on that day on January 6th.